want to talk to you more detail about
the pandemic and the new restrictions
being imposed tonight
on two million people across the
northeast of england
what's it going to look like how is it
going to manifest itself and newcastle
city council
nick forbes is joining the leader of the
council um hello to you thank you for
joining us on the programme
we're hearing that it's going to be
another lockdown what's that going to
actually
look like in real terms
good morning we're very concerned about
the exponential rise in a number of kobe
craters
across the northeast and our evidence
from contact tracing
tells us it's happening broadly in three
main areas that's in bars and pubs
in people's homes and in grassroots
sports
and so what we've done is try to get
ahead
of the curve and ask government for some
additional temporary restrictions
so that we can get on top of the virus
in all of those areas
that means restrictions on
a table service only in bars and pubs as
well as a 10 pm
uh closure of all uh bars and pubs
across our region and cafes
delivery service for takeaways only
after 10 pm and
restrictions on households meeting up
with each other outside of social
bubbles
we're hoping the government will give us
an exemption on informal child care
arrangements for extended family members
because we know how important that
is but we're asking people not to mix
outside of their own household
unless they're in a social bubble and
also some restrictions on major events
too i appreciate that these are not
easy measures and people have worked so
hard to get businesses up and running
again after the national lockdown
there's some might be some fear about
the impact of these
but we are working with businesses and
we want to ensure that
uh all of our businesses who work very
hard to ensure their code is secure and
kobe safe
continue to operate through this with
some additional measures
just to curb the spread of the virus
where we know uh the
spread is happening most prevalent yeah
so just to clarify these are the same
pubs and restaurants that we were given
financial incentives to go to
last month we're not being told that we
shouldn't go to them
or need to leave early
no people are very still very welcome to
go to bars and restaurants
the only change will be that it will be
table service only
that's to ensure social distancing in
all places one of the challenges that
we've got
is that we have a number of pubs where
people have been congregating around the
bars standing
and clearly it's very difficult to make
social distancing
when that's going on so table service
only and
a 10 pm finish a closure
for all pubs and restaurants that's to
ensure that
uh people can still get home uh safely
and aren't out because one of the
challenges has been
groups of people meeting up in our towns
and city centres very late at night
and again after a few drinks that means
social distancing goes out the window
so we want to ensure that that isn't
another opportunity for the virus to
keep spreading
but wasn't it table service only anyway
uh no the uh restrictions uh uh
that have the restrictions around that
were lifted uh which is why we're asking
for them to be
re-imposed and the other change is that
uh we're asking people not to go to bars
and restaurants
outside of their social bubbles or
outside of their households
that means that you shouldn't aim to
meet up with people
in the pub that you couldn't meet up
with in your home
so i appreciate that that's again a
restriction
on people but we think it's a necessary
restriction
as a preventative measure now to head
off
a much more damaging full lockdown which
would be the inevitable consequence
if we didn't act at this stage so you go
to the pub on your own and you billy no
mates and if your neighbor's there you
need to go home is that what you're
saying
what i'm saying is that none of us want
to be in this situation
we all know that this is challenging but
actually
if people say that this is about loss of
liberty there is no greater loss of
liberty
than the loss of life we've seen the
numbers of kobe cases go up
exponentially
we've seen it start to spread from
younger people into older generations
it's going up at more or less the same
rate as it was going up at the start of
the original first wave
and we know that that led to thousands
and thousands of deaths
and that's ultimately what we're trying
to prevent as some additional
preventative measures now will head off
further
real calendars down the line and that's
what i'm hoping the government will
confirm later today
but cancer if that is the case why don't
you just go for um a whole
um lockdown in in the northeast so
people the pubs are not open the
restaurants are not open and then we
don't see that figure spiking
because so many of our businesses in the
hospitality sector have worked so hard
to be covered secure the vast majority
of them
have done absolutely fantastic job i
think
i think it would penalize them if they
were forced to close just when they got
back on their feet again
we think at 10 pm closure which frankly
is only an
hour before they would normally close
for most of them is an appropriate
compromise and a way of keeping them
open
and keeping them in business as well as
ensuring that everybody understands and
gets the messages
around the real importance of social
distancing
which frankly after a few drinks tends
to go out the window but that's the
point isn't it alcohol and social
distancing don't mix do they so while we
were seeing this spike again
particularly in your areas
why not go for the whole lockdown
that's why we're asking for table
service only because
it's much easier to maintain social
distancing
if people are seated with table service
because you can literally see
where everybody is and there's much less
chance of coming into contact with
people
if unlike if you were actually mingling
at the bar
we've taken public health advice uh
we've worked with the hospitality
industry on this
and we're convinced and that this is a
safe way of ensuring those businesses
can continue to operate
but with some additional restrictions
just to make sure that social distancing
is effectively maintained for everybody
in those premises